better time to be involved in a
technology company and that is either
one that makes technology products and
or has the main primary strategy be
rooted in technology it's never been a
better time because the opportunities
and all sectors of Technology are just
exploding the issue is it's never been
more challenging to be successful in
those environments so this program takes
a look at every functional area what may
have been termed in the old days general
management of a particular firm and then
layers on top of that the real key
themes of this decade which is things
like innovation globalization developing
alliances and truly becoming a leader of
your enterprise
we have a
doesn't faculty assistant so each
faculty member teaches three or four
days somewhere in that neighborhood of
sessions these take place in the morning
using an MBA style format of case
studies and some lectures and so on is
very highly interactive this is what
they call experiential learning so
everybody comes to the classroom and
contributes but these faculty are very
very special we've chosen them because
they are the best at that particular
subject that we can gain access to we
have a celebrated author and professor
from here at Stanford robert sutton
who's just finished a book for example
is you know he's got a half a dozen
books but this one's good boss bad boss
and i got to get this right how to be
the best and learn from the worst so we
not only have tremendous learning going
on on the strategic aspects of running
one of these companies but also on how
to innovate to motivate and organize
after all this is still regarded as the
one of the primary centers of innovation
and technology in the world and when I
say this meaning Silicon Valley and
Stanford University so we take advantage
of that and in the way we execute the
program we spend mornings on lectures
but mostly case studies of both
successful and not so successful
scenarios of in all kinds of functional
areas of a technology company and then
evenings are spent in small study groups
with other executives not necessarily
from you know your own company where I
think that they turn out to be maybe the
most special part of the day because of
the intimacy involved
to be more than just a manager to be a
true leader in these enterprises at any
level and in any level is going to take
a special kind of person you can't just
understand a particular discipline or
technology you've got to have more
breath than that and leadership
creativity innovation and a basic
understanding of of the functional areas
of the business and we can do that and
we've proven we can do that with this
program for high velocity high tech con
adventures and enterprises